breaking news and the brutal killing of
Professor Joseph
weer what's this about blunt object to
the
head I'm
sorry I don't understand none of
it we'll be buring the electrodes in the
memory centers the temporal and parial
loes you sick way I'm doing a clinical
trial I forget a lot of stuff
[Music]
my doctor says I got to keep my mind
active Joseph weider's murder doesn't
make sense tell me how it really went
down I ain't no killer make it right or
I'm
dead he tells me he didn't do
it Richard
Finn he was at the crime scene why is
that what about Laura she's got no
address no social media nothing
there was always people visiting the
house it's a bit
strange just like everyone from weed's
life is now a ghost what are you trying
to
say if we've put away the wrong guy this
is a chance for us to make that
right move on I forget about all
this people kill for a whole lot of
different
[Music]
reasons you may not have memory but you
do have quite the
imagination